[Musique]
rien ne l'a prédestiné à devenir député
mon invité a été femme de chambre dans
un hôtel pendant près de 20 ans elle a
mené une grève victorieuse de 22 mois
contre son employeur et depuis son
élection elle s'efforce de porter la
voix des S voix à
[Musique]
l'Assemblée bonjour Rachel kké bonjour
alors vous êtes une combattante c'est
comme ça que vous vous définissez
vous-même une combattante dont la vie a
basculé quand vous aviez 12 ans en Côte
d'Ivoire quand votre mère est décédée ce
drame dans votre vie il vous a conduit à
prendre des responsabilités familiales
très jeunes très tôt vous avez dû
arrêter les études à 12 ans pour
travailler euh quand ma mère est partie
heureusement qu'elle m'a appris beaucoup
de choses donc à 12 ans je faisais
manger à mes à mes frères et à en même
temps je partais à l'école donc après en
classe de CM2 j'avais plus la force de
faire les travaux mélangés à la maison
et puis aller en même temps à l'école
faire les deux choses ensemble donc un
jour j'ai dit à mon père que je préfère
rester à la maison m'occuper de mes
frères que de continuer les études plus
tard vous êtes donc arrivé en France
vous aviez 26 ans vous avez vécu
notamment dans un squat avec vos enfants
à l'époque vous avez exercé plusieurs
métiers avant de devenir femme de
chambre à l'hôtel Ibis bâtignol à Paris
c'était en 2003 vous y avez sur place
enchaîné des cadences très soutenues
pendant des années jusqu'à 40 chambres à
nettoyer chaque jour pour 1300 € par
mois avec une tendinite au poignet que
vous avez eu des douleurs au dos et puis
au mois de juillet 2019 vous êtes mise
en grève avec une quarantaine femme de
femmes de chambre de cet hôtel on va
revoir ça en
image cela fait maintenant près d'une
semaine qu'elles occupent le hall de
l'hôtel Ibis où elles travaillent elles
sont femmes de chambre gouvernantes
toutes étrangères la liste de leurs
revendication est longue cadences
infernales obligation de laver soi-même
sa tenue de travail pas d'indemnité de
repas et même un cas de viol dénoncé
devant la justice beaucoup d'entre nous
connait pas le droit de travail donc ils
exploitent au maximum ils nous
exploitent au maximum alors ces images
qu'on vient de voir c'était le tout
début de votre combat je le disais ça a
duré 22 mois dans la pluie dans le vent
dans le froid qu'est-ce qui vous a fait
tenir aussi longtemps sans salaire mais
ce qui nous a fait tenir déjà c'est les
conditions qu'on traversait dans cet
hôtel h et avec la sraitance on était
mal payé on avait des assements sexuels
on avait des assements moral on était
tellement mal traité donc ça franchement
fallait qu'on soit de ça et c'est un
métier sachez que qui rend malade qui
donne des tendignit tu donn mal au dos
des poigné qui qui qui sfent des épaules
qui se déboîent c'est un boulot très
très très pénite et très mal payé et là
nous ça nous a donné la force de pouvoir
sortir du silence pour mettre fin à ça
alors à l'époque vous étiez élu CGT hein
au sein de de cet hôtel vous êtes imposé
un peu comme la la leader de de cette
grève le député LFI Erric coqurel qui
est venu vous soutenir plusieurs fois
sur place dit de vous elle a quelque
chose qui magnétise elle est forte elle
a les mots justes elle n'a pas besoin de
lire et il vous qualifie de leader de
masse est-ce que vous saviez que vous
aviez ce don là de d'emmener les autres
avec vous de transmettre une énergie de
porter leurs paroles avant cette grève
mais oui parce que au départ quand j'ai
j'ai commencé à faire le métier des
femmes de chambrees je voyais les
justice qui se passait et beaucoup de
femmes de beaucoup de de ces femmes ne
savaient pas lire écrit et moi je me
prenais tout le problème dessus donc je
les défendait donc quand il y avait
elles avaient un problème tout su elles
cherchait elle est où rachel est où
Rachel et malgré même que j'étais pas
délégué syndicat je partais devant le
patron et je les défendais pour leur
dire c'était pas normal c'est dans votre
tempérament c'est dans mon tempérament
j'aime pas l'injustice voilà c'est comme
ça là où il y a l'injustice franchement
je n'aime pas mais je c'est dans le bon
sens quoi je je j'essaie de trouver des
solutions pour ces femmesl donc ce
combat vous l'avez gagné le 25 mai 2021
euh votre employeur a accepté
d'augmenter les salaires de payer des
heures supplémentaires vous a accordé
aussi une prime pour les repas il a
accepté de baisser les cadences de
ménage et alors un an après avoir gagné
ce combat vous avez accepté d'en mener
un autre quand la France insmis vous a
proposé d'être candidate au législativ
est-ce que vous avez hésité à vous
lancer en politique quand ils m'ont
proposé d'être candidate au législative
j'ai dit ah c'est pas c'est un peu
compliqué comment est-ce que je connais
pas la politique mais bon et après le
président de la France Insou qui me dit
non mais vous avez mené une lutte
victorieuse et que je sais que à
l'Assemblée nationale vous pourrez nous
représenter et j'ai pris confiance en
moi parce que oui on a gagné une on a
gagné une grève très victorieuse pendant
22 mois mais pourquoi ne pas être la
voix des S voix à l'Assemblée nationale
et là on voit votre première prise de
parole lors de du lancement de la Nupe
vous avez mis toute la salle debout
quelques semaines plus tard vous avez
donc été élu député face à une ancienne
ministre he Roxana maraciné à nous le
soir de votre victoire vous avez déclaré
j'ai le niveau CM2 je dis merci aux
journalistes qui vont se mettre à mon
niveau euh on sent quand même une forte
dose d'ironie dans cette déclaration ça
vous a agacé le regard que les
journalistes ont pu porter sur vous à
l'époque sur votre parcours il y a des
journalistes qui sont un peu méprisant
mais bon je j'ai dis oui je sais que ils
vont prendre pour m'attaquer je sais
qu'ils vont m'attaquer mais je suis une
guerrière je les tiendra tête si un
journaliste me pose une question que je
ne comprends pas je ne réponds pas mais
je n'ai pas peur
journaliste pour répondre euh les
premiers pas à l'Assemblée c'est
toujours un peu compliqué pour n'importe
quel député qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
difficile pour vous euh déjà à
l'Assemblée nationale la télévision
quand je regardais souvent les autres
députés avec la cravate je me dis mais
wouh avec des gens qui sont formés qui
ont bac plus 5 que ça va être un peu
voilà ça va être ça allait être un peu
difficile pour moi et comment est-ce que
j'allais y arriver pour comprendre les
rouages comment ça se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale mais enfin je j'ai
compris que il faut se former et ça m'a
beaucoup formé j'ai j'ai compris
beaucoup de choses et je commence à
comprendre encore beaucoup de choses
vous aviez promis d'être la vois des S
voix de ceux qui s'occupent de ce que
vous appelez les métiers essentiels et
qui sont pas ou peu représentés à à
l'Assemblée vous l'avez fait dès votre
première prise de parole dans
l'hémicycle et puis vous l'avez fait
avec plus de force encore pendant la
réforme des retraites puisque vous étiez
chef de fil des députés LFI sur le sujet
de la pébilité on va revoir un extrait
d'une de vos prises de
parole qui d'entre vous a déjà fait un
métier pénible qui d'entre vous peut
lever la main et dire moi aujourd'hui
j'ai dû pousser des chariots avec 50 de
kil de ciment j'ai dû m'occuper de 20
personnes âgées qui peut lever la main
personne vous n'avez pas le droit de
mettre en genou les gens qui tiennent la
France debout c'est pourquoi vous
voterons contre cette réforme de
retraite nous serons je vous remercie ma
chè
[Musique]
collègu je vous remercie c'est fini on
sent que vous vivez à 200 % vos vos
prises de parole vous êtes vous êtes à
fond oui je suis à fond parce que c'est
un sujet qui me tenait vraiment à cœur
parce que euh faire travailler quand
même les gens 2 années de plus jusqu'en
64 ans sans penser euh à des métiers
pénibles c'est quand même dommage parce
que par exemple moi à l'époque quand
j'étais femme de chambre est-ce qu' a 64
ans est-ce que je peux faire rien et
alors mais il y a il y a quand même
aussi cette façon de pointer du doigt
vos collègues députés ou les ministres
qui d'entre vous a connu ça est-ce qu'il
faut forcément avoir connu les métiers
pénibles pour pouvoir voter une loi sur
ce sujet-là mais j'ai dit oui parce que
quand tu sais quand tu connais quelque
chose tu fais beaucoup attention moi
aujOurd'huii c'estd vous vous abstenez
sur les les sujets politiques que vous
ne connaissez pas personnellement dans
ce cas-là mais ça avant de je je
m'abstiens si je comprends pas je
comprends que je sais que on m'explique
l'amendement ce que ça veut dire mais je
ne m' pas si ça va dans mon dans mon
cadre ou bien dans vers le cadre du
peuple parce que moi le problème comme
j'ai dit je suis la voix des S voix mais
c'est pour représenter le bas peuple si
ça va dans dans l'intérêt du peuple mais
je voilà je je ne m'assin pas euh votre
vie depuis votre élection a radicalement
changé ne serait-ce que parce que votre
salaire a a plus que triplé je crois
est-ce que vous avez peur au bout d'un
moment de vous déconnecter de ce que viv
les gens que vous voulez représenter
mais je ne me déconnect pas parce que je
sais d'où je viens quand tu sais d'où tu
viens l'argent ne peux pas faire que tu
vas te déconnecter parce que tu as tu as
eu des amis tu tu comprends les gens il
faut vous vous êtes encore en relation
avec vos Cies cè de l'ôel ibisd oui oui
oui je vais à l'hôtel Ibis je vais les
voir je vais parler avec eux je leur
explique comment ça se passe et leur
regard à vos anciennes collègu sur vous
est-ce qu'il a changé non ça n'a pas
changé au contraire elles sont très
contentes euh d'être être là où je suis
elles sont vraiment heureuses parce que
même un jour j'ai été Mon' dit tu sais
souvent quand les clients viennent ici
il nous disent ah mais c'est ici est
parti la la la femme de chambre qui a
été qui est à l'Assemblée nationale donc
c'est une F voilà c'est une fierté pour
elle et voilà je vais là-bas je leur
donne les les conseils on parle et même
quand le directeur d'bis il me voit il
vient il me dit mais madame la députée
vous pouvez venir pour qu'on puisse
discuter parce que je suis de près eu
leurs conditions de travail pour ne pas
que le pire arrive encore si ce qu'on a
vécu pendant les 22 mois vous êtes la
première femme de chambre à avoir été
élue député ça fait de vous un symbole
il y a beaucoup de gens hein vous venez
de le dire qui se reconnaissent en vous
qui ne se sentit pas représenté avant à
l'Assemblée et qui aujourd'hui se
sentent représenté vous pensez que
bientôt il y aura beaucoup d'autres
Rachel kké à l'Assemblée mais je veux
bien je vous croez c'est possible mais
ça peut être possible ça dépend des
partis politiques mais comme l'a faire
pour moi la France insoumise je pense
que d'autres parties comme le les
macronistes voilà le le RN je pense
queil faut qu'il propose certaines
personnes comme qui vientent du bas peup
parce que l'Assemblée nationale je pense
que c'est on est mieux représentés ceux
qui font ces métiers sont mieux
représentés à l'Assemblée nationale et
pourront mieux défendre eux-mêmes le le
leurs conditions de travail en face du
gouvernement euh un dernier sujet juste
après votre élection il y a un site
d'extrême droite F de souche qui a
révélé que vous avez relayé des messages
de soutien à Marine Le Pen en 2016
qu'est-ce que ces messages disent de la
Rachel kké de cette époque est-ce que
vous êes tu es sensible aux idées de de
Marine Le Pen à l'époque euh c'est pas
vraiment ça parce que vous savez quand
tu vas au travail tu tout le monde est
tu as le portable à l'époque je te
connaissais pas la politique voilà tu as
ton portable tu partages tu regardes
sans comprendre exactement ce qu'il se
passe voilà donc c'est pas que moi j'ai
jamais euh voté Marie Le Pen je il y a
pas une photo bien il y a pas une image
qui prouvve que j'étais à un r une
manifestation de mari de Pen non ça
n'existe pas en vant je comprenais pas
la politique que faisait Marie Le Pen
mais depuis que j'ai été élu j'ai j'ai
compris beaucoup de choses surtout
envers euh les les immigrés comment il
ils font leur politiques envers les
comment ils créent il créent la division
entre les Français il y a il y a un
autre sujet aussi euh qui a été révélé à
ce moment-là c'est qu'en 2018 vous avez
relayé un message de soutien à Bachar
al-Assad un message qui qualifiait la
France de prédateur criminel pour quelle
raison c'était mais comme j'ai dis je
n'aime pas l'injustice parce que je
voyais aujourd'hui on défend le cause de
la Palestine voilà c'est c'était un peu
pareil comme voilà la politique de
bacharass aujourd'hui je sais pas parce
que d'autres me ditent non mais il est
dictateur il est ceci mais à l'époque je
savais pas qu'il était dictateur moi je
voyais seulement que les bombardements
et je trouvais que c'était pas juste
c'est tout mais je savais pas qu'il
était il était dictateur il était comme
ça à l'époque je le savais pas
maintenant je
sais on va passer à notre quiz à présent
euh donc je vous explique le principe je
vais commencer des phrases et ça va être
à vous de de les compléter vous êtes
prêt ok on y va quand une éditorialiste
me reproche de porter un boubou dans
l'hémicycle mais moi ça me fait rire ça
vous a fait rire parce que c'est ce qui
s'est passé euh oui oui j'ai vu j'ai vu
mais ça me fait rire parce que je suis
venu j'étais pas en boubou je sais pas
d'où sort l'idée de Boubou donc ça m'a
fait rire en fait d'accord vous l'avez
pris avec humour voilà mon principal
défaut c'est ah mon défaut moi mon
défaut c'est j'aime rigoler beaucoup
parce que souvent me dit mais toi tu
prends tout à la légère bon je sais pas
si c'est un défaut mais bon voilà enfin
si je ne suis pas réélu en
2027 que FZ je ferai d'autres choses il
y a plein de choses dans le monde il y a
beaucoup de choses vous resterai quand
même engagé en politique oui je ser je
resterai engagé je vais pas baisser les
bras surtout je ferai euh comment je
peux dire je je vais me mettre dans une
ONG pour défendre les femmes donner la
force aux femmes de ne pas baisser les
bras de continuer la lutte de voilà
d'aller de l'envant parce que dans la
vie tout peut tout peut tout peut être
possible la combattante jusqu'au bout
voilà il faut qu'on batte jusqu'au bout
merci beaucoup Rachel keké d'avoir été
l'invité de la politique et moi
[Musique]
merci